Christmas! Some know it as the most wonderful
time of the year, a time for snow, hot chocolate,
family, and a sense of magic in the air. Others
know it as a time of stress, last-minute shopping,
canceled flights, and relatives you’d rather
not be stuck in a room with. No matter how
you feel about Christmas, there’s one thing we
can all agree on: it only comes once a year.
Right? Well, that might be true in most of the
world, but the SCP Foundation came across one
particular little town where the Christmas party
never stops, for better or for much, much worse.
SCP-784 is a neighborhood in a small Texas
town, made up of twenty-four houses and
two apartment buildings. Every last one of
them is decorated top to bottom in bright,
twinkling Christmas lights. No matter how hot
it is outside, and Texas summers can be brutal,
the ground is always blanketed with at least
twelve centimeters of snow. Curiously, there
is never any visible snowfall happening in the
neighborhood that would explain this. The snow is
just always there. It might look inviting from the
outside. A quaint little neighborhood where the
snow never melts and the Christmas lights never go
out. But the folks at the SCP Foundation know by
now that things are rarely ever what they seem.
All of the houses in SCP-784 are occupied by
beings referred to as SCP-784-1. They appear
to be completely ordinary, mostly adult humans,
dressed in traditional Christmas sweaters. There
are approximately 300 people living in SCP-784,
and they appear to age like normal
people, though no deaths of SCP-784-1
have ever been observed. The citizens of
SCP-784 spend their time doing activities
exclusively associated with Christmas and the
Holiday season. They sing Christmas Carols,
perform Christmas pageants, throw eggnog
festivals, give gifts, and decorate their homes.
When the sun goes down, the activities
turn to acts of Christmas-themed vandalism,
decorating any object or living thing deemed
“not cheerful enough” by any means necessary.
When a Foundation supply convoy stopped near
SCP-784 for the night in order to refuel,
they got to experience this maniacal
dedication to the Christmas Spirit first-hand.
First, the Foundation vehicles were egged,
drawing the attention of the personnel on
board. As the Foundation operatives chased off the
egg-based assailants, they left several vehicles
unattended. When they returned, they found their
vehicles and equipment changed into something
a bit more festive. First, they noticed that
a Humvee had been converted into a sleigh.
Then, upon checking the inventory of a weapons
shipment on board, they realized the fragmentation
grenades had been replaced with glass Christmas
ornaments, and antlers had been welded onto
the 156 safety helmets in their possession.
Unsettled by these changes, and the speed at which
the seemingly human instances of SCP-784-1 had
been able to make them, the personnel attempted to
drive away. When they started their engines, they
were shocked at a loud sputtering sound and bursts
of nutmeg-scented smoke. While they were gone,
their fuel tanks had been filled with eggnog.
If this encounter wasn’t enough to demonstrate
that SCP-784 was not to be trifled with,
there were several incidents of SCP
Foundation Agents entering the bounds
of the neighborhood and failing to adequately
perform the required Christmas celebrations.
When someone’s Christmas Cheer is not up to par,
instances of SCP-784-1 in the vicinity respond
immediately and aggressively, incapacitating
the offending person, and forcing them into
the nearest house. Five different Foundation
Agents have been abducted in this way so far.
The first Foundation Agent to be abducted was
Agent Paulson. While patrolling through SCP-784,
dressed in a Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer
sweater and a Santa hat, Agent Paulson made the
grave mistake of wishing a passing person,
“Happy Holidays!” In the blink of an eye,
the mood around her darkened. Eight stone-faced
people with their Holly Jolly attire surrounded
Agent Paulson. She attempted to draw her weapon
to defend herself but simply was not fast enough.
Thrashing and screaming for help, Agent
Paulson was dragged into a nearby home,
kicking over an inflatable snowman on the way in.
Next, Agent Matthews was on night patrol when a
bout of spontaneous caroling broke out. He joined
in singing Silent Night in an attempt to blend in
with the instances of SCP-784-1. Unfortunately,
he misremembered the lyrics to the song and began
singing the third verse while everyone else was
on the second. While still singing, the citizens
overwhelmed Agent Matthews and tied him up with
a string of decorative red and green lights.
Agent Sanderson, who was supervising the patrol,
attempted to intervene and free Matthews,
which attracted the attention of more
instances of SCP-784-1. Both Agents
were overwhelmed by the crowd, restrained,
and pulled into a home for what can only be
described as Christmas Carol Reprogramming.
Observers heard the sound of Christmas
Carols being sung inside for several days after.
While on his patrol, Agent Anderson tripped and
stubbed his toe hard against a Santa Claus-themed
lawn gnome. Overwhelmed by pain and irritation,
Anderson swore loudly and violently for a duration
of fourteen seconds. At the sound of his salty
language, three instances of SCP-784-1 sprang into
action and grabbed Anderson before he could react.
Two held his body in place, restraining
his arms, and forcing him to his knees.
The third held his head still, tilting
it back, and forcing his mouth open.
A fourth instance emerged from a house, carrying
a quart of eggnog. As Anderson struggled,
to no avail, the eggnog was poured into his mouth
until the quart was empty, and he collapsed limply
on the ground. Once he was rendered unconscious,
the instances of SCP-784-1 dragged him inside.
Finally, Agent Davids was observing the
neighborhood when he was offered a present
by one of the few children in the town, a young
girl wearing a sparkly green and red sweater,
and a headband decorated with reindeer antlers.
Davids accepted the gift with a forced smile and
thanked the little girl, but apparently
did not respond with enough enthusiasm.
When he failed to give the reaction she was
looking for, the little girl tackled him
with a surprising amount of force, grabbing him
around his legs and knocking him to the ground.
Before he could regain his balance and climb
to his feet, several more children emerged
from a nearby house and dragged Davids
inside, pulling him by his arms and legs.
Between one and three days after they were
taken, the abducted personnel emerged from
the house they were pulled into. They were all
dressed in new, more elaborate Christmas wear,
from light-up sweaters to headbands covered in
tiny presents. When a supervisor attempted to
extract the Foundation personnel, the personnel
refused to leave. When the issue was pressed
further, the instances of SCP-784-1 around them
became increasingly aggressive, and even violent,
in their attempt to protect the abducted
agent. Paulson, Matthews, Anderson, Sanderson,
and Davids are still within the boundaries of
SCP-784 and are considered lost. The official
story is that they died in the line of duty, in
order to protect their families from the truth.
SCP-784-1’s fixation on Christmas Spirit
doesn’t only extend to humans and inanimate
objects. Any living being within the walls
of SCP-784 that doesn’t look festive enough
is subject to a swarm of citizens decorating it,
and that includes animals. During several patrols,
Foundation personnel have observed fifteen
stray cats given red collars with a small bell,
seven stray dogs adorned with reindeer
antlers, rabbits and raccoons with Santa
hats forced onto their heads, and even a deer
dressed up to resemble the iconic Rudolph.
Out of an abundance of caution, and in an
attempt to prevent any future abductions,
there have been extreme limits placed on the
number of staff allowed to patrol inside of
SCP-784. The Foundation currently only sends in
agents under special circumstances, most notably
for a regular occurrence known as a Noel Event.
About once a month, instances of SCP-784-1 will
attempt to exit the boundaries of SCP-784 and
enter a nearby neighborhood in the suburban
community that surrounds 784. Each member of
the community carries a 15-meter-long string
of Christmas lights, and they wander in a group
until they have found an undecorated house.
They will begin to promptly decorate this
house, winding the Christmas lights around it
until it looks identical to the rest of the
houses in SCP-784. It is unclear what happens
to the residents of the chosen house, but it is
likely that they are converted into SCP-784-1,
much like the abducted Foundation agents.
Naturally, the Foundation has a vested interest in
preventing SCP-784 from expanding and is dedicated
to tracking and preventing these Noel Events.
Noel Events do not happen on an exact schedule,
but the Foundation has become aware of certain
warning signs that one may be coming. Prior to
a Noel Event, SCP-784-1 become more actively
festive during the day, notably increasing their
singing, decorating, and eggnog consumption.
When these signs have been noted, a select team of
personnel is ordered to execute Procedure 784-C,
a preventative measure employed to
stop the Noel Event from occurring.
When Procedure 784-C has been ordered to
commence, Foundation personnel dress up in
Santa outfits and position themselves by the exit
points of SCP-784. They sing the classic carol
“Good King Wenceslas” and pass out nonalcoholic
eggnog to the other personnel stationed with them.
Naturally, this draws the attention of SCP-784-1,
unable to resist the allure of holiday cheer and
goodwill toward men. Once they have arrived, the
personnel distribute a secondary batch of eggnog
to SCP-784-1, this one mixed with a mild sedative.
After the drugged eggnog has been passed out,
the Foundation personnel are to sing carols
with the citizens of SCP-784 as the sedative
takes effect. As instances of SCP-784-1 begin
to pass out, their neighbors will silently carry
them into their designated homes on their
own until all of them have fallen asleep.
If Procedure 784-C happens to fail for
any reason, the Foundation personnel
are instructed to release a sleeping gas into
the town and restrain the citizens until they
have been rendered unconscious. Then, they are
all to be placed in their homes by personnel.
If the members of any nearby communities express
concern, a standard cover story of a neighborhood
football watch party gone a little too far - AKA
“Drunken Football” is released to the public.
In order to prevent civilians from accidentally
happening upon SCP-784, the neighborhood has been
disguised as an ordinary gated community. It is
surrounded by a 3.5-meter-high, 0.8-meter-thick
concrete wall, topped with an electrified steel
cable. The Foundation is not allowed to prevent
non-Foundation personnel from entering, in order
to mitigate the risk of a violent reaction from
SCP-784-1. However, when an individual
not related to the Foundation is spotted
leaving the neighborhood, they are to be swiftly
detained, interrogated, and given an amnestic.
No Foundation personnel are permitted to enter the
neighborhood unless they are dressed in Christmas
attire. These personnel must also be armed with
the knowledge of all basic Christmas Carols.
The area is to be monitored at all times via
a Foundation-owned weather balloon, and the
citizens of SCP-784 are to be watched for unusual
behavior and the signs of an impending Noel Event.
SCP-784 is currently classified as Euclid, and is
considered to be largely non-threatening as long
as it continues to be contained. The citizens
of SCP-784 are not overtly harming anyone,
and they don’t seem to want anything more
than to celebrate Christmas forever. However,
it’s uncertain how far they would attempt to
expand if Noel Events were allowed to occur
with no intervention. Perhaps
they would expand forever,
forcing eggnog down throats and strangling
houses with twinkling lights, turning the world
as we know it into a twisted snow globe.
Hopefully, we’ll never have to find out.
Just be careful if you’re wandering through
the suburbs of Texas and hear the jingling
of sleigh bells in July, or you might
find yourself on SCP-784’s Naughty List.
Now go check out “Trapped in a Game -
SCP-1733 - Season Opener” and “The Skin
Stealers - SCP-3333 - Tower” for more
places you hope to never find yourself!